un bonjour à tous ravis de vous
retrouver sur public sénat poursuivre
dans un instant les débats des sénateurs
autour de la réforme du dialogue social
focus ce soir sur un article qui a été
discuté hier soir au sénat
l'article 19 bis qui reconnaît le burn
out comme maladie professionnelle
cela a été un amendement qui a été
rajoutée par l'assemblée nationale
mais le sénat lors de l'examen en
commission a supprimé cette disposition
il a continué à supprimer sa disposition
également hier soir en séance publique
en effet les sénateurs estiment certes
que le bernois est en augmentation en
france mais il pense aussi que le burn
out n'a pas pour seule cause des causes
professionnelles qui peut également y
avoir des causes personnelles un être
également ils estiment qu'ils n'ont pas
eu le temps de réfléchir correctement à
la question avec cet amendement qui a
été rajoutée par l'assemblée nationale
et il préfère donc renvoyé cette large
aux questions de maladie psychique
professionnelle à la loi santé loi qui
sera examiné par le parlement est
débattu en séance publique au mois de
septembre tout de suite donc retour à la
séance hier soir au sénat nous parce ans
à l'article 19 bis qui avait été
supprimé madame david vous avez la
parole
merci madame la présidente rapidement
sur cet article 19 bis qui traite de la
préservation de la santé au travail je
voudrais m'exprimer sur les amendements
qui ont été déposés sur le burn out par
nos collègues socialistes et écologique
qui reprennent l amendement déposé par
benoît hamon à l'assemblée nationale
cette reconnaissance
demandez donc dans les amendements
serait un premier pas vers la
reconnaissance des pathologies
psychiques comme maladie d'origine
professionnelle en tant que première
avancée nous serons donc favorable à ces
amendements
cependant nos chers collègues vous ne
pouvez pas d'un côté prétendre dans le
vouloir ferrat
on sait les droits à la santé des
salariés lorsque de l'autre côté vous
supprimer en tout cas vous fusionnez les
chsct dans lé délégation unique du
personnel
cette contradiction est d'autant plus
forte que comme nous l'avons rappelé
vous réduisez le rôle et l'importance du
médecin du travail dans les entreprises
c'est la démonstration que vient de
faire mon collègue dominique watrin
alors certes avec ses amendements il
s'agira d'une avancée que nous voterons
mais d'une avancée dans un océan de
recul pour les salariés si madame david
et trois amendements identiques le 66
qu'il a défendue par me cdc servent ou à
la parole ou chers collègues
cet amendement vise à rétablir une des
avancées du présent projet de loi un
amendement commun des députés
socialistes du gouvernement votée par
l'assemblée nationale à savoir la
reconnaissance de burn out comme maladie
professionnelle
aujourd'hui à l'heure de la performance
des objectifs de plus en plus difficile
à atteindre
la pathologie la pathologie de physique
devient de plus en plus psychique
si la déposition de bernal relève du
domaine médical et je sais qu un
important débat a lieu sur cette
question il est toutefois de notre
responsabilité en tant que
parlementaires de prendre une décision
politique afin d'affirmer clairement
qu'un modèle productif qui atteint les
travailler en plus profond de leur être
n'est pas acceptable
pour ce faire deux solutions s'offrent à
nous on peut d'une part inscrire burn
out dans les tableaux des maladies
d'origine professionnelle et ainsi
financer la prévention et la réparation
par le biais d'une contribution à tmp du
travail maladies professionnelles
représentent principalement sur
l'employeur cette solution apparaît
comme la plus pérenne mais elle
nécessite un véritable dialogue social
sur cette question voilà pourquoi nous
vous posons nous vous proposons plutôt
comme cela a été fait à l'assemblée
nationale de reconnaître en dehors du
tableau des maladies professionnelles
par les comités régionaux de
reconnaissance des maladies
professionnelles
il est en effet possible aujourd'hui
pour les personnes concernées de faire
reconnaître leur maladie auprès de ses
comités des leurs qu'ils
dépasse un certain seuil d'incapacité
définies par décret ce seuil est
aujourd'hui trop 25% à titre d'exemple
un ouvrier qui perd sa main sur un
chantier atteint appelle le taux de 20%
c'est pourquoi nous laissons latitude au
gouvernement pour définir la procédure
et les modalités de traitement par
décret la démarche proposée par les
députés le gouvernement et à laquelle
nous nous associons est souple et j'ai à
mettre en oeuvre
elle permettra d'initier la prise en
compte la fiction qui touche de plus en
plus de concitoyens
si monsieur c'est ça le sens 808
rectifié est identique qui les défendent
je vous en prie madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre chaque collègue la
structure nouvelle du monde du travail
avec la fin des grandes unités de
production le rythme de travail les
horaires excessif la mise en concurrence
de tous contre tous les objectifs
souvent inatteignables est de plus en
plus élevés les exigences de rentabilité
toujours plus grande
très des conditions de travail
génératrice de stress et d'angoissé
seul les risques de nature physique ont
été pris en considération pendant
longtemps
aujourd'hui ces nouvelles conditions de
travail ont abouti à l'émergence de
risques psycho sociaux dont on a pris
conscience et qui génère parfois des
syndrome d'épuisement professionnel burn
out
l'opinion a été alerté par des suicides
survenus dans des bureaux d'études des
grandes entreprises
à la suite de réorganisations menées
parfois brutalement
il n'est d'ailleurs pas indifférent que
c'est syndrome de burn out se soit
manifestée dans cette catégorie
d'entreprises ou les méthodes de gestion
du personnel et plus innovantes
parfois les plus inhumaines sont mises
en oeuvre ces éléments ont été
remarquablement analysées par nos
collègues gérard dériot et jean pierre
godefroy des leur rapport de 2010 sur ce
sujet concrètement le problème est que
toutes les personnes n'ont pas la même
sensibilité à ces mutations des
conditions de travail et à ses méthodes
de management
de plus le burn out peut être mais pas
toujours multifactorielle c'est pourquoi
il est aujourd'hui toujours pas inscrit
au tableau des maladies professionnelles
pour autant il est avéré que certaines
pathologies psychiques ont une origine
professionnelle ne souhaitons donc que
ces pathologies puisse être prise en
compte comme maladie professionnelle
dans les conditions prévues par
l'article l 461 1 du code de la sec
vite et social cela suppose que dans
chaque cas la maladie soit
essentiellement est directement causés
par le travail habituel de la victime et
qu'elle est entraîné le décès de
celle-ci ou une incapacité permanente
la caisse primaire reconnaître alors
l'origine professionnelle de la maladie
après avis motivé du comité régional de
reconnaissance des maladies
professionnelles
bien entendu cela ne dispense pas et
bien au contraire d'une démarche de
prévention en direction des entreprises
avec l'implication des services de santé
au travail
je vous remercie merci mes chers
collègues le 274 identique aussi du
gouvernement il est défendu
il est défendu
monsieur le ministre car ici oui mais
non je ne suis pas encore frappé par le
syndrome d'épuisement professionnel et
donc c'est pour ça que l'amendement du
gouvernement qui complète les deux
amendements qui viennent d'être
présentés par madame ryoko à l'instant
il vise à revenir sur un an à reporter
la suppression par la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat de la pleine
reconnaissance des pathologies
psychiques en particulier le syndrome
d'épuisement professionnel par des
comités régionaux de reconnaissance des
maladies professionnelles qui a été
introduite par l'assemblée nationale
en effet il ya eu à lyon des as long
débat les maladies psychiques qui sont
liées au travail et en particulier ce
syndrome d'épuisement professionnel sont
une réalité que personne ne peut nier ça
c'est un fait
et d'ailleurs si vous voulez si vous
vouliez le nier ce fait les médias
seraient là pour vous rappeler tous les
matins que c'est un vrai sujet
d'actualité l'intensification des
rythmes de travail
des exigences qui peut qui peuvent peser
sur les salariés doivent nous a cité en
tous les cas à une part de vrai pour une
meilleure prise en compte
reconnaissance de ces pathologies et de
leur lit et de leur lien avéré fier avec
les conditions de travail de ses
salariés et donc il est essentiel quand
même que ces pathologies soir reconnu
mieux reconnus d'autant plus qu'ils
n'exigent qu'il s'agit là en
l'occurrence de pathologies complexes
très complexe qui ne rendent pas
nécessairement dans ce que le code du
travail a appelé de manière classique
les maladies professionnelles
nous en sommes parfaitement d'accord et
donc je crois que la bonne
la bonne entrée sur ce sujet ou la bonne
voie c'est de permettre une
reconnaissance de ce syndrome
d'épuisement professionnel par les
comités régionaux de reconnaissance des
maladies professionnelles
donc on renvoie aux
ou comités régionaux d'ailleurs c'est le
sens de l'article 19 bis du projet de
loi que le gouvernement propose de
rétablir par amendement je pense ça
serait un progrès important dans la
reconnaissance alors à dire les choses
autrement du burn out
le gouvernement va proposer d'autres
mesures qui ne relève pas de la loi mais
qui vont dans le même sens la
composition des comités qui seront
appelés à se prononcer sur la
reconnaissance de ce syndrome nom
notamment sera revu pour intégrer des
médecins psychologues camps sont
examinées des cas potentiels de burnout
la priorité absolue
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure la priorité
absolue c'est le renforcement de la
prévention
c'est pourquoi l'élaboration d'un grand
plan de santé au travail a été lancé
avec un fort consensus
je lui ai dit tout à l'heure entre les
partenaires sociaux sur les orientations
et je voudrais le faire à nouveau saluer
ici même leurs investissements et
l'importance de leur contribution
parallèlement j'ai installé au mois de
février de cette année un groupe de
travail spécifique sur ce syndrome sur
le burn out sur ce syndrome qui a
produit un guide un vin documents de
prévention un guide de prévention d'une
grande qualité à destination des acteurs
de l'entreprise
les partenaires sociaux ont salué
largement la qualité de ce guide
dans un avis qu'ils viennent tout juste
de rentrer il a assisté en raison de le
faire sur l'aspect central de la
prévention de la prévention en matière
de burn out et ils sont pleinement
mobilisés sur ce sujet on ne peut pas
considérer le syndrome d'épuisement
professionnel commune pas comme une
maladie comme les autres maladies
professionnelles comme les autres parce
que la reconnaissance de qualité de ma
vie professionnelle au sens du code du
travail c'est quelque chose qui est liée
aux postes de travail ont bien
évidemment d'autres facteurs peuvent
entrer en compte dans la rentrée ont
rencontré dans la prise en compte de
cette ce syndrome d'épuisement
professionnel ses pensionnaires que
l'approché difficile et qu'il vaut mieux
privilégier d'où l'idée de ce guide de
prévention
prévention voilà le sens de l'amendement
merci monsieur le ministre
avis de la commission sur ces trois
amendements identiques madame la
rapporteure comme je suis ministre a
rappelé l'article 19 bis tel qu'il est
issu du texte à l'assemblée est issu de
modifications apportées par le
gouvernement qui consacre au niveau
législatif les pathologies psychiques
dans l'article l 461 1 du code de la
sécurité sociale
il laisse mais vous l'avez dit monsieur
le ministre gouvernement définir par
décret ces pathologies
le président millions s'est expliqué
tout à l'heure et là des compétences
médicales que je n'ai pas je veux
simplement dire que la commission a
évité ni à l'avis défavorable à ces
amendements de rétablissement et aussi
pour une deuxième raison c'est que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est qu'il y
a à l'heure actuelle les auditions sur
la loi santé il semble que ça suppose un
petit peu plus de réflexion
en tout cas dans la précédente dans la
rédaction que ce que le temps que nous
n'avons pas eu d'ailleurs au sénat
surtout cet article ce qui renforce
l'avis défavorable de la commission
mais si madame le porter je n'ai pas de
demande si mais c'était après il s'est
bâti je savais la parole
monsieur le ministre madame le
rapporteur mes chers collègues je ayant
été à l'origine de cette suppression de
ce que vous voulez rétablir donc je dois
quelques explications
il n'est pas question de nier que le
surmenage ou d'épuisement au travail
puisse puisse exister mais de là à aller
un concept burn-out pathologie psychique
qui sont assez difficiles peut être à
cerner et à mesurer précisément et dont
les causes sont souvent multiples avec
une répartition d'origine raison bien
sûr personnel raisons familiales raisons
sentimentales fragilité de la
personnalité et raisons professionnelles
qui peuvent effectivement existé il est
difficile de faire la part de sacs
origines il lui sera sans doute
difficile et je ne vois pas comment je
dirais les comités régionaux de
reconnaissance de ma vie professionnelle
même avec des expertises de niches de
psychologues ou de psychiatres arrivants
effectivement à dernier à déterminer si
la raison essentielle et cela peut
exister dans certains cas je le
reconnais la raison essentielle est
d'origine d'origine professionnelle
il y à côté de cela et je voudrais pas
qu'on compare des malades des maladies
professionnelles évidente et
malheureusement irréversible il
semblerait que le burn out de ce que
j'en sais du ce que j'en ai lu soit
plutôt un état temporaire et non pas un
état définitif et dans la mesure où
c'est un état temporaire peut-on
qualifier de maladies professionnelles
semble-t-il
donc je crois qu'il faut éviter
d'introduire et d'allonger la liste des
maladies professionnelles
en dehors de celles qui sont évidentes
du effectivement postes de travail due à
l'inhalation de certains produits la
miranda et à d'autres à la certaine un
certain nombre de choses qui paraissent
évidentes et un caractère physique
puisque là on rentre dans des choses qui
sont je dirais tu si site donc des fois
un petit peu plus
irrationnel on a d'ailleurs en avant
garde et ce sera peut-être un prochain
débat c'est le bord à août qui arrivent
je n'ai pas lu mais certains collègues
m'ont fait part d'article c'est l'ennui
au travail je dirais qu'ils pourraient
être une nouvelle pathologie dans la
mesure où le travail d'une personne ne
serait pas suffisamment en valorisant et
donc ne serait pas ne travaillerait pas
suffisamment il ya toute une thèse qui
est développée là dessus donc on peut
continuer mais pour être plus sérieux et
plus concret je pense que la plupart des
maladies existantes y compris des
maladies cardiovasculaires peuvent avoir
d'une part d'origine professionnelle
mais ce n'est pas une raison pour faire
porter je dirais tout le mal être de
notre société à l'entreprise parce que
je crois qu'il ya là un mauvais service
rendu à la notion de travail et à la
notion d'entreprise sans méconnaître le
problème que cela peut poser donc je
demande si j'ai demandé la suppression
de cet amendement d'origine qui figurait
dans le texte qui est arrivé au sénat
c'est plus par précaution et c'est pas
par négation
je dirais de situations qui peuvent
exister donc voilà le alors il faut pas
que dans les amendements de suppression
on relève une forme de stigmatisation du
travail et de l'entreprise même si
certaines entreprises par leurs méthodes
de travail
je dirais peuvent conduire à des états
dépressifs mais je pense que ce qu'ils
sont en droit de le tenir le plus
content et qui mériterait le plus
d'attention sont pas les gens qui sont
au travail sont les gens qui ont des
raisons réelles de déprime le ce qu'ils
n'ont pas l'emploi si monsieur gabouty
la parole est annoncée savary en tout
cas ce match
oui merci madame la présidente je
voulais remercier les explications du
docteur cette semaine parce que
véritablement les explications par
rapport aux burn out ont été des
explications d'ordre médical ce qui nous
fait quand même là aussi nous rejoindre
en pensant que c'était vraiment un
problème de santé et que ça va être
réglé dans le cadre notamment de la loi
santé pour lequel il ya déjà un certain
nombre d'articles qui sont là on et puis
après ça mérite d'être étudiée de façon
un peu plus profonde sur l'amendement
proposé notamment par monsieur
nécessaire je lis la souffrance
psychique générés par le monde du
travail
mais quand on analyse de façon un petit
peu plus fine tous là où on voit bien
que c'est pas aussi simple que cela
parce que sinon nous aurions déjà trouvé
les solutions
j'avoue je me suis penché sur ce
problème autant que tant qu'on peut
cumuler c'est comme ça responsable d'un
exécutif avec près de 2000 personnes et
quand on fait le bilan social
obligatoire mais très intéressant de ce
projet pourra les causes notamment
d'arrêt maladie avec un certain nombre
de problèmes liés effectivement à une
ambiance au travail que pour lequel et
je partage ou un peu je vous rejoins là
dessus pour lequel véritablement il est
important de prendre des mesures de
prévention
parce que ont des têtes un petit peu ça
quand on analyse un peu plus finement on
voit bien que c'est toujours en rapport
avec certains il ya dans ces affaires-là
d' de difficultés au travail
il n'y a pas que le comportement d'un
individu c'est le comportement de
plusieurs individus qui font que
l'ambiance est telle que certains ne
n'arrive plus à vivre correctement leurs
activités de travail
maintenant quand je regarde ça sur le
plan médical et quand on est confronté à
ces gens qui ont des problèmes
psychologiques en rapport notamment avec
leur travail on voit bien que dans plus
de la moitié des cas il n'y a pas que le
problème de travail aussi une ambiance
familiale des difficultés qui font que
accumulé ces différentes causes
conduisent à effectivement ce que l'on
peut appeler un épuisement au travail à
travers le terme français né au bout
on ajoute d'ailleurs pas de travail mais
burn out c'est à dire l'impression
d'incompréhension dans un certain nombre
de deux car parfois c'est une pathologie
sous jacente
j'ai eu l'occasion aussi de rencontrer
ça avec des problèmes cérébraux de
tumeurs cérébrales qui faisait qu'il ya
un comportement au travail qui était tel
que on arrivait à travers effectivement
ces difficultés comportementales de
faire une analyse qui pouvait conduire à
des pathologies eux qui n'avaient rien à
voir avec le travail
locke c'est un sujet me semble-t-il
particulièrement compliquée qui mérite
qu'on s'y penche de façon plus précise
avant d'introduire cela comme une
imputation au travail avec des
répercussions sur l'entreprise une
pénalisation donc financière des
entreprises parce que plus vous allez
d'accidents de travail ou de maladies
professionnelles déclarées plus vous
avez un taux de cotisations pour les
entreprises importantes alors que c'est
pas aussi évident que cela pour imputer
directement cette pathologie au travail
donc je rejoins la conclusion de
monsieur gabouty on est souvent
confronté également au burn out ou aux
comportements dépressifs d'un certain
nombre de personnes qui n'ont pas de
travail est véritablement il faut se
pencher également sur tout cela parce
que imputer cela au travail je ne suis
pas sûr que ça aide à comprendre ceux
qui n'ont pas de travail à l'évolution
sociétale par rapport à cela puisque le
but est véritablement à travers une loi
sur le dialogue social de faire en sorte
que tout le monde puisse s'épanouir dans
du travail à condition de pouvoir en
fournir savary la parole est à monsieur
gilbert barbier pour expliquer cette
date
merci le président finit chaque collègue
je ne voudrais pas si les amendements
pour diverses raisons y en a qui ont des
traits évoquait simplement on parle de
pathologies psychiques faut savoir qu'il
ya une définition qui existent aussi
qu'ils sont les troubles psychiques
est-ce que c'est pareil ce qu'elle
centre dans cette pathologie des global
première interrogation on a fait un
paquet pathologie psychique
d'autre part l'autre problème qui va se
poser inévitablement s'agit-il d'une
pathologie psychique ou psychiatrique
parce que la délimitation est très
délicate parce que vous dire que c'est
l'objet de discussions approfondies de
savoir si c'est un trouble psychiatrique
qu'on pourrait acquérir au travail ou si
c'est simplement un trouble psychique
donc ça c'est un problème
en plus de ça vous le savez tout le
monde le sait on parle souvent de
pathologies psychosomatique
alors comment va-t-on s'est retrouvé là
dedans de faire un énorme package
pathologie psychique
on va faire rentrer je ne sais pas au
moins de deux ou trois sans symptômes
qui pourraient être évoquées dans ce
domaine donc je crois que c'est assez
compliqué d'autre part c'est un problème
qui risque de poser problème au salarié
lui-même parce que on peut être avoir
des troubles psychiques est entré dans
une entreprise travaillait dans une
entreprise mais à ce moment là et je
pense que les les employeurs vont se
trouver dans une situation s'est demandé
quel est l'état psychique de chaque
salarié qui vont embaucher pour éviter
d'avoir à un moment donné on convient de
reprocher voilà j'ai d'une pathologie
psychique qui était acquise
je crois que c'est sa part d'une à bon
sentiment moi je suis bien d'accord qu'à
un moment donné il faut reconnaître ce
problème là mais c'est sauvé la limite
n'est pas facile à discerner
voilà je crois qu'il faut absolument
travailler cette question est peut-être
que la loi de santé que nous allons en
train d'étudier
c'est un vaste domaine il ya eu des
rapports du sénat sur le problème de la
santé mentale monsieur le président la
commission des affaires culturelles
sociales le sait bien on entre dans un
donne l on ouvre
véritablement quelque chose qui sera
impossible à contrôler donc je ne
voterai pas non pas pour être contre le
6 le fait éventuellement on puisse
reconnaître une origine professionnelle
à des troubles qu'ils soient psychiques
ou psychiatriques ou psychosomatique
mais cet amendement me paraît trop trop
généraliste s'est pas assez précis
madame j'ai mis son poing explications
de vote
non non mais merci madame la présidente
non mais je pense que le sujet est très
complexe
il est très complexe il est très
compliqué il est contraint comme l'a dit
notre président de commission il est
sont de plus rare qu'on ne le pense mais
néanmoins il existe
notre collègue gilbert barbier vient de
faire une démonstration intéressante sur
la différence que l'on peut trouver
entre les troubles psychiques et les
problèmes psychiatriques
on a quand même connu une situation
absolument dramatique avec un commandant
de bord qui si on avait étudié mieux son
cas médical et son cas médical de
travail aurait peut-être évité la mort
de combien non c'était pas à burnout
mais on a parlé actuellement de troubles
psychiques et de problèmes
psychiatriques
oui mais il ya quand même nous devons
quand même y compris en médecine du
travail ne pas nous contenter d'examiner
la situation physique d'une personne par
un post and par rapport à un poste de
travail mais également toute la
personnalité de la personne par rapport
à ce poste de travail je crois que c'est
vraiment un sujet un sujet important et
d'ailleurs les médecins du travail que
nous avons auditionné pour l'examen de
la loi santé nous l'ont dit avec avec
force je pense que on peut pas dire que
parce que le sujet est difficile qu'il
ne faut pas le traité et on peut pas non
plus dire que il ya bien évidemment les
gens qui travaillent qui peuvent être
éligibles burn out mais il ya également
et c'est vrai les troubles psychiques
voix psychiatrique des personnes qui
sont en recherche de travail qui était
également un vrai sujet moi j'avoue que
je suis assez comment dire perplexe non
pas par rapport aux sujets à traiter
mais par rapport à l'amendement
alors même qu'on veut pas dire non plus
parce que c'est complexe et que c'est
difficile on le traitera toujours après
j'ai envie de dire que monsieur le
ministre vous le proposer dans ce texte
sur le dialogue social
peut-être la déformation professionnelle
fait que je considère qu'il a aussi sa
place dans la loi de santé publique
ils sont jeunes et plus de demandes
d'explications de vote donc je vais
mettre aux voix
ces trois amendements identiques avec un
avis défavorable de la commission on
avisera de ceux du gouvernement
puisqu'il est dans les trois amendements
qui est pour cet amendement qui et
contre qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas
adopté l'article 19 bis reste donc
supprimés nous arrivons à l'article 19
terre avec une demande de parole de
monsieur watrin oui madame la présidente
pour rappeler que nous n'avons jamais
été groupe crc défendu compte pénibilité
une façon quelque sorte de faire passer
plus facilement la dernière réforme des
retraites c'est-à-dire le recul
progressif de l'âge de la retraite à 62
ans
dès le départ nous avons souligné ses
effets limités le départ des plus âgés à
61 ans un des plus jeunes postulants
dans le cadre des 100 points du conte
pénibilité au mieux a 60 ans nous avons
dit dès le début que ce système ne
permettait pas une véritable prise en
compte de la pénibilité
une question pourtant essentielle du
fait de l'intensification de la
productivité du développement des
maladies professionnelles liées bien
souvent la recherche maximale du profit
nous avions proposé au groupe crc une
toute autre piste le départ anticipé à
la retraite pour tous les salariés ayant
exercé des métiers pénibles
finalement c'est tout le contraire qui
était fait avec le comte pénibilité un
système à la fois compliquée et limiter
ses limites sont d'ailleurs tellement
évidente que le gouvernement nous
propose à l'article 19 sexies de revoir
drastiquement à la baisse sur
cotisations pour les entreprises dont
les salariés sont exposés aux facteurs
de pénibilité en faisant passer le taux
de 0 3 à 0 1% et le taux de 0 6 à 0 2 en
cas de poly exposition rappelons que la
loi sur les retraites du 10
8 12 2013 prévoyait entre 0 3 0 8% pour
un facteur de pénibilité on ne peut pas
exact et plus clairement des reculs en
réalité on le sait le gouvernement a été
soumis dès le départ aux pressions du
medef est forcé de concepts constater
qu'ils cèdent sur tous les fronts
monsieur valls a d'ailleurs parlé d'
adresser un message de confiance aux
entreprises au nom de la simplification
il reporte l'application de cette
facteurs d'exposition sur dix il baisse
la participation patronale
et cerise sur le gâteau pour le medef il
supprime la fiche individuelle
d'exposition à ce qui pourrait nous
faire passer pour des adeptes de la
surenchère ou des maximaliste voudrais
ici rappeler ceci depuis la loi du 9
novembre 2010 le code du travail article
l 41 21-3 un mentionne que l'employeur
doit consigner dans une fiche les
conditions de pénibilité auxquelles le
travailleur est exposée la période au
cours de laquelle cette exposition est
survenu les mesures de prévention mises
en oeuvre pour faire disparaître ou
réduire ces facteurs or à ce jour les
employeurs n'ont aucunement répondu à
cette obligation puisque ces documents
n'existe toujours pas dans de nombreuses
entreprises
ceux ci prétendent se préoccuper de la
pénibilité mais refuse la plupart du
temps d'assurer la traçabilité des
expositions subis par les travailleurs
pour faire valoir leurs droits voilà la
réalité
or la traçabilité c'est bien la question
essentielle pour faire d'abord de la
prévention pour recenser les postes
pathogènes et postes de travail et
obliger les employeurs à les transformer
car le but premier c'est bien d'éviter
l'altérité de la santé au travail plutôt
que de reculer sans cesse le
gouvernement serait donc mieux inspiré
de retravailler cette question de la
traçabilité en 47 en 1947
ce sont les cramer les carsat qui ont
été chargés sans succès de cette tâche
depuis 2011 et services de santé au
travail
1100 moyens voilà toutes les raisons qui
nous ferons voter contre cette partie
merci la parole mme et à monsieur qu'a
dit pour deux amendements identiques ou
monsieur calvi merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre ce
chapitre premier qui transforme
l'élaboration des fiches de prévention
déclaration on voudrait qu'ils ne
conduisent pas les entreprises à devoir
avoir plus de travail
nous fêtons une simplification pour les
entreprises et donc nous proposons que à
la ligne à 5 coups on évoque la
déclaration est soit stipulé que cette
déclaration soit effectué annuellement
ceci permettrait d'éviter un surcroît de
travail pour les entreprises
merci vous chers collègues de 285 crédit
fier monsieur lemoine où il était
parfaitement il rejoint le d'amendements
précédemment présentés donc on voit bien
que
les entrepreneurs doivent faire face à
un certain nombre de déclarations plus
ou moins récurrente
on pense par exemple à tes déclarations
tva pour les artisans c'est chaque mois
et mine de rien voilà c'est ça prend du
temps et c'est pas toujours au coeur du
métier de ces artisans siger entreprises
et donc voilà dans le souci
effectivement de faire en sorte de ne
pas alourdir
toutes ces déclarations l'idée est bien
de préciser qu'elle se fait une fois
dans l'année
annuellement voilà moines avis de la
commission madame le rapporteur sur ces
des amendements identiques
merci tout d'abord le rapporteur veut
rappeler que le sénat ait de la majorité
sénatoriale sont satisfaits d'avoir été
entendu et de voir que la fiche
individuelle de pénibilité a été
supprimé s'agissant des deux amendements
identiques qui ont été présentés et il
porte sur le caractère annuel de l'année
de la déclaration d'expositions à des
facteurs de pénibilité il a déclaré et
la déclaration se fera dans le cadre de
la dsn déclaration sociale nominative
auprès de la carsat ou de la cnav en une
de france ou d'une thèse générale de
sécurité sociale dans les départements
d'outre-mer mais l'adsl et mensuels et
la fiche d'exposition annuelle par
rapport à l'amendement donc par rapport
à cette double du hadith cette dualité
j'aimerais savoir tel est l'avis du
gouvernement puisque j'ai on n'a pas pu
émettre d'avis compte tenu de cette
situation
merci maintenant à porter je n'ai pas de
demandes d'explications de vote
pardon l'avis du gouvernement j'allais
vous oubliez ministre
et vous aussi d'ailleurs vous aviez à
vis de ces sur ces voies je reprends
pour qu'on soit bien au clair entre nous
on est sur les articles l'article 19 ter
et les amendements 19 et va terrifier le
supplée dit que 285 qui est le dessin 85
19 et 26 fille de monsieur k dick alors
on ne l'est pas encore pris d'accord ok
on le verra après donc c'est le 19è 285
rectifier c'est le même veine
amendements bon alors ça a été un long
combat de simplifier la fiche de
pénibilité parce que la pénibilité c'est
une longue histoire
je ne veux pas vous la raconter mais
j'ai des fois j'ai envie parce que je la
raconte quand même parce que ceux qui
sont les plus critiques sur le
dispositif sont ceux qui l'ont mis en
place et donc en 2003 non c'est juste
une jettent les bases 2003 vous
connaissez réforme des retraites
monsieur fillon accord avec une
organisation syndicale importante est
donc prise en compte première de la
pénibilité renvoie aux partenaires
sociaux
2008 est posé sur la table le principe
de la pénibilité il n'est pas actée par
les partenaires sociaux il sait pas et
le la fiche pénibilité continue son
chemin elle est validée définitivement
dans le cadre de la prévention je le dis
bien par le ministre du travail en
novembre 2011 qui crée la fiche
individuelle de pénibilité avec lesdits
facteurs tels qu'ils sont définis et
donc c'est repris par l'actuel
gouvernement dans sa complexité dans sa
complexité je le dis bien à l'occasion
de la réforme des retraites c'est la
même histoire qui se continue et moi je
considère depuis le début que pour que
la pénibilité puissent être prises en
compte parce qu'il faut prendre en
compte la pénibilité on peut appeler ça
autrement 1
enfin puisqu'il faut prendre en compte
la pénibilité et bien il faut que ça
soit compréhensible et que ce ne soit
pas une tâche compliquée insurmontable
pour les petites et moyennes entreprises
heures pour le coup on se rejoint enfin
ceux qui sont là aujourd'hui parce que
quand même c'est les mêmes qui avaient
voulu faire la complexité avant donc je
propose la suppression de la fiche
individuelle
la fiche individuelle d'entreprise pour
le suivi des six facteurs qui reste à
mettre en oeuvre puisque vous savez
qu'il y en avait 10 donc c'est assez
simple à partir de là il n'y aura qu'une
déclaration annuelle qui sera faite par
l'entreprise parce que il faut que ça
soit simple compréhensible par le
salarié opposable et donc on renvoie aux
branches pour l'accord est donc
l'entreprise n'aura on a vérifié avant 4
ou simplement déclaré l'état pour le
salarié donné les facteurs une fois dans
l'année une fois dans l'année
et pourquoi alors je m'opposerai à la
phrase enfin l'ajout de l'adverbe
annuellement
tout simplement parce que il pourrait y
avoir au terme de l'année civile dans le
cadre d'un contrat accords étaient
passés en cours d'année la fin du
contrat et à ce moment là c'est pas
forcément annuellement c'est à la fin du
contrat
c'est la seule explication mais sinon on
pourrait se rejoindre je dis donc que
cette présence cette précision proposé
est inutile et pourrait complexifier la
vie des entreprises
merci monsieur munissent myners a par
terre j'avais demandé la rue vis du
gouvernement je propose effectivement
soit le retrait soit effectivement un
sous-amendement mais sinon leur retraite
monsieur cannoise et vous retirer votre
amendement vous le maintenez j'ai pas
compris donc vous le maintenez non ma
maison si vous vous retirez le regard
des autres il est retiré sont retirés le
vérifier mécanisée madame la présidente
c'est concernant les l'alinéa qui
concerne la linea 15 qui vise
expressément les travailleurs détachés
non affiliés à la sécurité sociale en
france et on souhaitait que ceux ci
soient précisées dans le texte de façon
à ce que ce soit clair pour tout le
monde à l'avis de la commission est
effectivement le gouvernement doit nous
expliquer pour que ce soit clair
mais si le ministre à vis du
gouvernement pour ce soit clair je
comprends bien sûr de cet amendement
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que les
travailleurs détachés ne peuvent pas
effectivement acquérir de droits dans le
cadre du compte pénibilité mais ils sont
pas les seuls il ya des fonctionnaires
qui bénéficient d'autres modalités de
prise en compte de la pénibilité les
salariés de droit privé
pourtant s'il ne bénéficie pas de poids
puisque ils n'ont pas de point retraite
pour enfin de deux gains de points soit
pour la formation soit pour la prise en
compte de deux mois deux trimestres de
retraite
il est important que leur exposition à
la pénibilité soit connu de façon à
améliorer pour eux aussi le suivi de
leur état de santé sur le long terme
d'ailleurs dans la lutte contre le
travail des tâches et non déclarés la
prise en compte du salarié le respect
des conditions de travail de sécurité de
protection du salarié détaché est prise
en compte donc moi je pense que votre
demande de précision que je comprends
pose un problème au niveau européen et
continuerait constituerait pendant
consisterait à écarter une partie des
salariés visés par cette baisse
position elle ne crée pas de droits mais
je pense que les écarter a priori n'est
pas conforme à l'esprit qu'on se fait de
la prise en compte de la santé des
travailleurs détachés déclaré je dis
bien déclare est gelée zoute
malheureusement on ne connaît pas ou on
les connaît qu'après avoir constaté le
fait qu'ils étaient sur les lieux de
travail de manière non déclarés merci
monsieur le ministre ce cas ne vais vous
vous le retirer je vais donc revoir
l'article 19 ter qui est pour les
comptes tu s'abstient il est adopté
mes chers collègues je consulte
l'assemblée pour vous proposer de
prolonger la séance jusqu'à minuit et
demi si vous à mettre d'accord c'est bon
pour tout le monde donc mais pas tant de
burnout mais c'est aussi ça alors tout
va bien donc il n'ya pas l'observation
et 20 mhz et ainsi décider cet
amendement qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune mais c'est qu'à nager
pour les actes et à rectifier et il y
aura ensuite identique pour les 286
rectifier merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre chaque collègue sur
3 alinéa de cet article 19 quater on
propose considérons que l'élaboration de
référentiels de branche ne peuvent se
résumer au reclassement des salariés par
métier sauf à accepter la création de
nouveaux régimes spéciaux et donc on
propose de retirer la spécificité par
métier mais c'est qu'à mes amendements
identiques de selouane il est défendu
merci beaucoup à la présidente
oui donc voilà il s'agit effectivement
dans cet article 19 quater d'enlever
cette référence aux métiers pour garder
la référence aux situations de travail
ou au poste je m'explique
l'idée si vous voulez des auteurs de
l'amendement
c'est d'éviter de stigmatiser tel ou tel
métier car on sait qu'on a un certain
nombre de métiers dans ce secteur de
l'artisanat effectivement parfois c'est
un peu dur qui ceux qui ont du mal à à
trouver à recruter d'ailleurs c'est un
des sujets de notre marché du travail
avec eux je crois cinq ou six cent mille
offres d'emploi qui ne sont pas
satisfaites qui sont pourtant qui
existent qui sont là et naturellement
l'attractivité des métiers est quelque
chose qu'on doit prendre en compte donc
c'est vrai que fait référence dans le
texte de loi sur ces dispositions
pénibilités à la notion de métier ne
paraît pas forcément la meilleure chose
compte tenu de ce contexte j'ajoute que
l'article 19 quater comme l'expliquent
très bien madame le rapporteur dans son
rapport page 157 cet article transpose
la recommandation numéro cinq du rapport
du député christophe sirugue qui étaient
missionnés sur ce sujet et pardon oui je
faisais référence aux bourguignons d2 et
et qui précisaient qu'ils précis et donc
je lis un la recommandation numéro cinq
du rapport sirugue qui ne fait pas
référence à la notion de métier
justement dans sa dans sa recommandation
numéro 5
il parle bien de préciser dans la loi
que des accords de branche étendu ou des
référentiels professionnels et ceux dont
on parle
homologuée par les ministères tac tac
tac peuvent déterminer l'exposition des
travailleurs aux facteurs de pénibilité
au regard des seuils précis dans le
décret à partir de situations types
d'exposition faisant notamment référence
au poste occupé et aux mesures de
protections collectives et individuelles
dont il n'y a pas de traces des métiers
dans dans l'art dans le rapport qu un
cocon rendu
les deux éminents collègues et chefs
d'entreprises et donc voilà je vous
proposerai de centre de nous en tenir à
au rapport sirugue rien qu'au rapport
est donc de ne pas fermer à paraître
cette notion de métier qui encore une
fois peut stigmatiser certains métiers
merci monsieur même en 1984
monsieur le ministre mais là je présente
le l'amendement du gouvernement
interviendrait après sur les autres on
est bien d'accord on est bien d'accord
l'amendement donc que je présente visa à
rétablir la rédaction je ferai tout ce
que je vous réponde avant mais donc la
rédaction de cet alinéa qui permet à des
référentiels professionnelles de branche
homologué l'affût il n'y a pas de
difficulté de déterminer alors des
métiers les postes de travail de
situations de travail exposés à la
pénibilité
je dois dire que ce qui a été voté à
l'assemblée nationale
dans la foulée des conclusions de la
mission hulot sirugue virville
d'ailleurs je ne l'oublierai pas c'était
la possibilité d'élaborer par des
référentiels professionnelles de branche
sakho 6 1 c'était considéré c'est
considéré comme une avancée importante
c'était attendu par les
les entreprises notamment et aussi par
les organisations qui voulait que ça
s'applique donc il faut que les
déclarations des employeurs soient
sécurisés pour rendre le dispositif
pleinement applicable ce qui est la
condition indispensable pour garantir
les droits des salariés concernés donc
la situation financière du fonds
évidemment un poids de vigilance majeur
et donc elle ne peut pas être un critère
d'homologation des référentiels par les
pouvoirs publics donc ça reviendrait à
priver de l'utilité des référentiels
certaines branches est donc à fragiliser
d'une certaine manière les droits des
salariés couverts mais j'aurai
l'occasion de répondre plus précisément
aux à l'amendement que vous avez
développé et c'est le ministre un
monsieur bien élevé pour le 22 et le 23
s'il vous plaît merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre shah
clinker concernant le 22 il s'agit de
considérer que l'ouverture d'une
négociation au niveau de la branche ne
doit pas être un préalable à l'ouverture
de la possibilité pour l'organisation
professeur de branches de définir
unilatéralement les postes situations de
travail concernés ça c'est le 22 et le
c'est un amendement qui vise à préciser
plus clairement la possibilité laissée
aux accords ou un référentiel
d'introduire des dérogations et non
seulement des modulations par rapport
aux définitions et dont conseil de
pénibilité débilité de droit commun il
me fait qu'attiser le sang neuf madame
aubry aimeraient dumas vous faites le
synafel 110 il madame la présidente et
compte tenu de l'exposé qu'a fait
monsieur le ministre pour l'amendement
du gouvernement nous allons retirer nos
deux amendements sur 910 très bien je
vous remercie mes chers collègues avis
de la commission sur le 21 rectifié
d'abord de monsieur k 9 et madame le
rapporteur et 284 et ici parce qu'ils
sont identiques
sur l'article sur 20 l'amendement 21
rectifié l'actuel article du code de
travail indique que les accords
collectifs de branche étendu peuvent
caractériser l'exposition des
travailleurs à des facteurs de risques
professionnels à travers des situations
types faisant notamment référence à des
postes occupés par les salariés
l'article 19 ter issu de l'amendement du
gouvernement complète cet article en
ajoutant aux postes les métiers et les
situations de travail
donc on a trois notions là le post le
métier la situation de travail qu'ils
sont reprises par coordination pour les
référentiel élaboré unilatéralement par
les organisations d'employeurs de
branche
la crainte de certaines organisations
patronales et que la référence aux
métiers aboutissent à octroyer des
poings par principe et sans discernement
à des catégories entières de salariés
qui exercent le même métier
votre commission partage cette crainte
et elle a souhaité d'ailleurs est votée
que l'homologation de ces référentiels
par les ministères concernés n'entraîne
pas de dérives dans les dépenses des
fonds chargé de financer ce dispositif
et c'est une réelle inquiétude il
compris des partenaires sociaux donc sur
la questions techniques soulevées par
l'amendement 21 je demande la ville du
gouvernement y compris sur le 286 qui
est identique qui a été présenté dans la
foulée sur vous voulez la vie sur le 184
millions de résidents qui s'il est bien
il est forcément défavorable parce que
il revient
et leur revient au texte de l'assemblée
mais pire encore il supprime ce que nous
avons souhaité introduire à la
commission des affaires sociales
c'est-à-dire la soutenabilité financière
le deuxième volet qu'il paraît très
important et qui paraît très important
pas seulement à la commission des
affaires sociales au sénat pour ne pas
que l'on crée de nouveaux régimes
spéciaux
donc avis défavorable merci il est 22
c'est vous qui le 22 je souhaite l'avis
du gouvernement je comprends l'intention
de l'auteur de l'amendement
je crois que ces préoccupations pourrait
être satisfaite dans les faits parce que
le projet de loi ne donne pas de date
butoir pour l'accord de branche étendu
les organisations patronales pourront
donc entamer des négociations
et si elle constate qu'elles sont trop
longs de reprendre en main
l'élaboration unilatérale du référentiel
mais je demande quand même l'avis du
gouvernement sur cette analyse le 23
recchi simon important le 23 rétifié
alors par contre là le sucre élevé c'est
un avis défavorable car il autoriserait
des référentiels de branches à déroger
sans limite au seuil d'exposition à des
facteurs de pénibilité définis par voie
réglementaire
ces dérogations ne sont pourtant cadres
et ne sont pas encadrées et aboutirait à
supprimer l'idée même du conte
pénibilité avec des règles fixées à la
carte
je suis défavorable au 23 la commission
est défavorable au 23 mai le rapporteur
n'a ses ministres du gouvernement sur le
21 rectifier les 286 rectifié terre et
dans toutes ces deux abonnements vous
venez d'évoquer madame la présidente
le 21 elle 286 qui sont d'ailleurs
identique je le redis l'objectif
principal c'est de rendre le dispositif
du compte personnel de prévention
la pénibilité est effectif un hors-jeu
de justice sociale inutile que je
rappelle que l'espérance de vie est
fortement différente suivant le métier
que vous exercez l'espérance de vie dans
la profession mais aussi l'espérance de
vie tout court que simplifier le comte
pénibilité que vous nous avez laissé
avec sa complexité pas vous directement
bien évidemment mes précédents ministres
et sécuriser sa mise en oeuvre
c'est le rendre applicable pour trois
millions de salariés concernés pour cela
et ça a été vu avec les partenaires
sociaux
préalablement même à l'annonce je les
fais je les ai rencontrés
il faut donner toute latitude aux
branches pour pouvoir travailler de la
manière la plus pertinente possible en
fonction de leur activité
et c'est pas vous qui ne contredirait en
effet qui mieux que les branches est à
même d'identifier les expositions à la
pénibilité
même si on peut regretter cette
formulation telle qu'elle est ainsi fait
dans le langage propre à la branche en
fonction de l'activité exercée la
rédaction a été fait en accord avec le
rapporteur choix je pense pas qu'ils
souhaitent c'est bien d'en tête je pense
pas qu'il soit un schizophrène donc le
rapporteur sirugue qui après avoir
travaillé avec nous a considéré qu' il
fallait croiser l'analyse en termes de
métier ça a été dit de postes de travail
ou de situations de travail
il faut que les branches puisse
apprécier l'exposition de la façon la
plus pertinente possible sans qu'un seul
niveau de l'analyse leur soit imposé
c'est pourquoi il faut garder
l'expression des métiers exposés métier
situation de travail et donc c'est à la
demande des organisations syndicales
elles mêmes je répondrai à la partie
financière ensuite mais voilà pourquoi
je peux pas être favorable à cela parce
que si vous enlevez la notion de métier
vous enlever aux branches la possibilité
de définir même ce qu'ils allaient faire
le coeur de
la reconnaissance de la pénibilité pour
les salariés donc avis défavorable sur
ces deux amendements ou vannes ou
rectifier vous plaît monsieur le
ministre le 22 rectifié continue très
bien madame la présidente je continue en
disant le 22 rectifié je pense qu'il est
satisfait parce que effectivement le
texte actuel je lis bien la formulation
de l'amendement le texte actuel n'impose
pas aux branches d'ouvrir une
négociation avant de pouvoir élaborer un
référentiel et donc je pense que c'était
le sens de votre amendement le fait de
permettre à des référentiels de branches
homologué de déterminer l'exposition à
certains facteurs de pénibilité
vous ne contestez pas constitué une
avancée majeure en termes de
simplification du dispositif du comte de
pénibilité et sur tout sécurisation pour
les employeurs pour les salariés donc on
a supprimé la fiche individuelle
d'entreprise de suivi qui était
journalières je rappelle quand même au
début du mois si on voit ce que ça veut
dire
tout à l'heure il y avait une aide
incroyable à la petite entreprise
c'était c'était touchant c'était
touchant mais quand je regarde quand
même la complexité vous aviez laissées
pour les petites entreprises
préalablement donc là moi je suis très
heureux d'avoir pu résoudre dans l'ain
facteur de simplification et de mise en
oeuvre quelque chose qui était d'une
extrême complexité
et je pense qu'il faut garder les trois
positions que j'ai évoqué les métiers
les situations de travail et les postes
voilà donc pour ce qui est de
l'amendement 22 et je pense qu'il est
satisfait je vous demande de retirer
alors le 23 rectifier c'est la
possibilité d'ouvrir la possibilité aux
accords au référentiel de déroger au
seuil réglementaire de pénibilité bon là
il ya une simplification en personne le
compte est donc ces référentiels et
permettent de passer je le rappelle
d'une approche qui étaient individuelles
de l'exposition des salariés une
approche collective
la branche définira je le redis les
postes les situations de travail ou les
métiers qui sont exposés au delà des
seuils définis par décret
l'employeur pourra utiliser ces
référentiels pour déclarer une fois
l'exposition de ses salariés de façon
tout à fait sécurisé en revanche oui une
fois par an en revanche en revanche
permettent aux branches de déroger au
seuil c'est ce que vous souhaitez je le
redis dans les référentiels donc
permettre aux proches de déroger au
seuil dans les référentiels serait une
atteinte à l'égalité entre les salariés
donc cela pourrait conduire à ce que les
salariés qui ont la même situation de
travail dans des branches différentes ça
peut exister vous le savez soit pour l'a
reconnu comme exposé pour l'autre non ça
irait à l'encontre je crois de la
philosophie même de ce dispositif qui
est un dispositif de justice sociale et
qui veut que chaque salarié dans une
situation de travail identique même si
c'est pas dans la même manche est la
même considération en matière de
pénibilité donc l'avis est défavorable
sur celui là c'est le 23 merci monsieur
le ministre je vais mettre voit ses
différents amendements donc le 21
rectifié 286 présidente pardon vous
permettez je vous en prie parce que je
n'ai pas répondu c'est pour
s'interpellent comme cela sur le borgne
nous en voulaient pas j'ai pas répondu
aux problèmes financiers qui était
évoqué j'avais abordé rapidement madame
la rapporteure tout à l'heure parce que
là
c'est un problème qui est pris en compte
on va pas évidemment ne pas considérer
cet aspect financier
je crois savoir que c'est la même
organisation patronale lasser les
grandes entreprises qui se préoccupe de
cela et c'est pas les petites
entreprises c'est les grandes
entreprises donc là on est à front
renversé par rapport à ce que
j'entendais tout à l'heure tu vois que
ça vous préoccupe cette fois ci la
position du du medef
voilà je vais me référer à la position
des petites entreprises
je suis très heureux que cette
disposition que nous introduisons face
le 5e rang des satisfactions à jeûner
site à la cgpme a lu pea à la capeb à
tous ceux qui sont déjà toutes celles
qui sont des petites entreprises
là pour une fois le medef eh bien il
sait très bien qu'on trouvera les
équilibres financiers il se préoccupe de
cela c'est un horizon de 20 ans mais il
est normal de s'en préoccuper ça ne
transformera pas les choses on n'est pas
dans les régimes spéciaux
on serait dans des régiments créerait
des régimes spéciaux
s'il n'y avait pas ce référentiel de
branches se renvoient à la branche à des
situations de travail les postes de
travail et si c'était uniquement tous
les métiers qui étaient considérés tel
n'est pas le cas donc je voulais en même
temps vous rassurer madame rapporteur
merci monsieur mini jeu mais se voit
donc le 21 rectifier le 286 rétifié
terre avec défavorable du gouvernement
qui est pour elle pendant et et un avis
du gouvernement de la commission qui est
pour mabiala masselot p1
12 qui est contre
ils sont adoptés le 22 rectifier avec
elle tombe qui tombe le 184 du
gouvernement ils tombent aussi et le 23
à rectifier il ne tombe pas avec deux
invités retirer le 24 juillet monsieur
dame avait monsieur k dick
merci madame à préserver ce ministre le
pressentent abonnement propose qu'un
employeur qui appliquent le référentiel
de branches telles que proposées par cet
article soit présumé de bonne foi il
s'agit par cet amendement de sécuriser
juridiquement la situation des
employeurs qui auraient choisi
d'appliquer le référentiel de branche
qui sera homologué par un arrêté les
cours